Trascrizione: Manal Jahangir
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Questa sera abbiamo sentito storie
di matematica, fisica, cybersecurity,
tecnologia, energia.
E io cosa c'entro?
Io sono Alberto Cavallari,
sono un architetto
e questa sera, in contrasto forse
con le storie che abbiamo sentito,
o forse proprio affinché
le storie che abbiamo sentito
possono avere luogo,
io questa sera vi parlerò della noia.
Ecco: proviamo, voi che siete in sala,
a pensare le cose che vi danno noia,
e io ho provato a riassumerle
con dei disegnini.
La prima è andare alle poste,
fare la fila alle poste,
dire alla gente di stare
in fila alle poste;
la seconda è pianificare meticolosamente
un viaggio prima di partire;
e la terza è passare l'aspirapolvere.
Cose abbastanza banali e condivisibili:
però ce n'è un'altra
che oltre a darmi noia, vi confesso,
mi fa anche un po' paura,
ed è la routine.
Ora, se noi chiediamo a Google,
la routine è "un'abitudine
lentamente acquisita
per mezzo della pratica e dell'esperienza,
più comunemente a proposito
di una monotona
e deprimente consuetudine."
Quindi, una ripetizione
monotona e deprimente.
Ora facciamo un'indagine in sala.
Tranquilli, che nessuno
verrà chiamato sul palco,
quindi potete rispondere
in maniera serena:
alzi la mano chi si può
definire pendolare,
quindi che deve muoversi da un punto A,
tendenzialmente l'abitazione,
ad un punto B, il luogo
di studio o di lavoro,
in maniera ripetuta e continuativa.
Prego.
Non vedo molto, ma mi fido
che le abbiate alzate.
Ritengo di essere in ottima compagnia.
Bene, come nella mia presentazione,
il pendolarismo fa parte
della mia routine, della mia ripetizione.
E proviamo a fare un paio di calcoli,
perché checché se ne dica
anche gli architetti
sono in grado di fare i calcoli.
(Risate)
Se noi prendiamo in considerazione
il periodo dal 2001 al 2021-
nel 2001 iniziai a muovermi
con il treno per andare al liceo -
fino ad oggi, sono 20 anni.
E stimando circa 230 giorni all'anno,
al netto dei mesi festivi e dei weekend,
e moltiplicando questi
per il viaggio di andata
e il viaggio di ritorno,
sono la bellezza di 9200 viaggi.
Ora, se noi moltiplichiamo
questi 9200 viaggi
per i 40 minuti nominali
che l'azienda dei trasporti
dice di metterci per il mio viaggio,
e voi sapete quanto siamo
ottimistici in questa stima,
sono 368.000 minuti,
che convertiti in ore sono 6.133 ore,
che sono la bellezza
continuativa di 255 giorni.
Quindi, 255 giorni della mia vita
da pendolare, in 20 anni,
sono stati - è come se io,
per 255 giorni continuativi,
avessi continuato ad effettuare
il solito viaggio.
Che noia, direte voi.
Lo dico anch'io, perché infatti
stiamo parlando della noia.
(Risate)
Bene, questa è stata
un po' la mia reazione
alla fine di questi calcoli.
(Risate)
E dopo gli anni del liceo,
e una brillantissima carriera
di ben sei mesi in Ingegneria,
iniziai la Facoltà di Architettura,
e l'obiettivo di uno dei primi corsi
era quello di redigere
un diario di viaggio,
ovvero un quaderno dove,
mediante schizzi, disegni e appunti,
si potessero ripercorrere i passi
dei grandi maestri
dell'architettura del '900:
Le Corbusier, Frank Lloyd Wright,
Alvar Alto, Mies van der Rohe,
Adolf Loos, Louis Kahn, e via.
Questa modalità diventò parte di me,
tant'è che da quel momento io non mi muovo
senza una penna e un agenda;
ed è diventata un po'
la mia coperta di Linus,
e mi accompagna sempre nei miei viaggi,
mi aiuta a combattere la noia
di questi 9200 viaggi,
e anche le altre mie esperienze.
Ovviamente, le pagine si riempiono
di schizzi, disegni, appunti,
collages, frasi, pensieri, citazioni,
spunti che poi possono tornare utili
per i miei progetti attuali.
E ad un certo punto, è successa una cosa:
era il 2012, me lo ricordo bene,
stavo tornando abbastanza tardi
dall'università,
e il vagone era mezzo vuoto,
ma davanti a me avevo un passeggero,
e lui era completamente
assorto dal telefono.
Allora, dentro di me,
scattò una sorta di sfida:
dovevo riuscire a ritrarlo
senza farmi vedere.
Voi vi immaginate il mio stato
di angoscia e di paura:
ero sicuro che lui mi avrebbe beccato,
e avrebbe detto: scusa,
ma cosa stai facendo?
Beh, mi misi lì, e il risultato
che ne venne fuori fu questo:
un disegnino, anche
abbastanza brutto, direte voi.
Ed è quello che penso anch'io:
però la cosa che mi stupì
fu che lui non si accorse
minimamente di niente.
Quindi, andai avanti in questa sfida.
E i passeggeri diventarono due,
quattro, otto, 10, 20.
Era come se i passeggeri,
assorti dallo schermo del telefono,
e da un continuo movimento di scroll,
fossero continuamente estranei
a quello che succedeva loro intorno.
Bene: in questi miei viaggi,
ho ritratto i passeggeri più disparati,
ho ritratto passeggeri impegnati
in importantissime e vitali call
che probabilmente avevano a cuore
le sorti del mondo,
e che ci tenevano a condividere
con l'intero vagone -
(Risate)
e poi passeggeri assorti
in importantissime sedute di meditazione,
passeggeri rattrappiti
dal freddo più gelido, nei mesi invernali,
e squagliati completamente
nei nei mesi estivi -
e anche il contrario,
perché ogni tanto la temperatura
non è sempre regolata al massimo.
E poi passeggeri
che affrontavano la città,
Milano, la metropoli,
la capitale della moda,
in tutta la loro eleganza e il loro stile;
e passeggeri che sono ancora un po'
in cerca del loro stile,
hanno un dialogo aperto con lo stile.
Ho documentato i passaggi tecnologici:
passeggeri intenti a districarsi
dai fili delle cuffiette;
passeggeri con cuffie più grandi di loro;
e passeggeri che sembrano intenti
in monologhi teatrali,
ma che in realtà hanno solo
delle cuffie invisibili.
E passaggi generazionali:
bambini in gita,
adolescenti che probabilmente
mi associavano a loro
perché probabilmente
stavano anche copiando i compiti;
e le generazioni più adulte.
E poi, come vi dicevo,
mi porto sempre con me
la mia agenda e la mia penna,
e questo mi ha consentito
di affrontare anche i viaggi
e di poter ritrarre le diverse culture
di cui io ero ospite.
Ovviamente, ad un certo punto, pausa:
come tutte le nostre vite,
anch'io ho subito una pausa,
anche i miei viaggi
hanno subito una pausa.
E dopo i mesi di pausa forzata,
mi sono ritrovato a ritrarre
vagoni desolatamente vuoti.
I primi passeggeri che,
penso più per necessità che per volontà,
affrontavano i viaggi
e cercavano di interagire,
e prendere confidenza,
con questi dispositivi
di protezione individuale;
e come ben potete immaginare,
ora i passeggeri con la mascherina
sono la mia routine -
tranne in alcuni svariati casi.
(Risate)
Bene, questi passeggeri -
sono ormai raccolti in 20 agendine,
un iPad e qualche foglio sparso.
E il conto odierno - perché è
un viaggio sempre in movimento -
è di 715 disegni;
ma se ci pensiamo bene
sono 715 disegni che ritraggono 715 volti,
che sono 715 persone
che, dentro di loro,
hanno ognuno la sua storia,
che probabilmente è tanto interessante
quanto quelle che abbiamo
ascoltato qui oggi.
E questo mi ha fatto pensare,
perché c'è una contraddizione di fondo:
se ci pensate, il tema di questo TEDx
sono le connessioni,
e noi con questi telefoni
abbiamo la possibilità di essere connessi
a 100.000 km di distanza,
possiamo seguire
le evoluzioni tecnologiche
e l'approdo di nuovi strumenti
sui vari pianeti;
o molto più banalmente,
possiamo seguire le gesta
dell'influencer di nostro riferimento.
Però, questa cosa ci disconnette
completamente da chi abbiamo intorno:
e quindi, non riusciamo a percepire
che una persona davanti a noi,
a meno del metro della distanza sociale,
che è quello che avviene nei vagoni,
con uno strumento antitecnologico
come la penna e la agendina,
sta effettuando un'operazione
anti-tecnologica come un ritratto.
E questa cosa mi ha portato
a pensare a delle cose,
ad imparare delle cose
che questa sera volevo avere
il lusso di condividere con voi.
La prima è che la noia non sempre
è un'emozione negativa, anzi:
tante volte è essa stessa portatrice
di quell'energia che abbiamo dentro.
La seconda è che sta tutto a noi.
Sta a noi cambiare lo sguardo;
e saper cogliere,
dentro la nebbia della noia,
le più grandi occasioni.
La terza è che anche i disegni brutti,
come quelli che avete visto stasera,
sono capaci di portare delle storie;
e la quarta, forse la più importante,
è che anche noi, esattamente
come quei disegnini brutti,
dobbiamo forse a volte accantonare
la perfezione del contenitore,
ma essere fieri del nostro contenuto.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
E un'ultima cosa: la prossima volta,
state più attenti durante i viaggi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)